hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 29th 2017 what's going on how
are you um how you guys doing
happy Memorial Day happy Memorial Day
when you're supposed to be out there
remember the troops you're gonna be
getting hammered say bad shitty wife and
you later if apologize for what's going
on you [ __ ] soon to be fat [ __ ] huh
you got the you got the grill going bad
right we a little kielbasa
what are you guys making today huh what
[ __ ] animal had to get the old right
there Fred you know in an uppercut to
another one you [ __ ] sewed them
together what God's name do you have on
your grill right now that you know you
[ __ ] what'd you put in there a bunch
of cheese who wants cheese on your
burger
come on these things are gonna [ __ ]
burn Carrie um oh you know what's the
best you put the buns on that's that's
the you know you keep checking to keep
checking me you're looking at the meat
don't want to burn the bunt Christ they
burned this one yeah burn I bet she
swallows I'm sorry
so why bill why why did you have to take
the nice family day that this is you
know that the great men of this country
fought so you could go out there you
know work you slowly work your way take
another step towards a [ __ ] massive
cordon Airy how many people are going to
faceplant to their grill today via too
much alcohol you know just eating that
last thing that [ __ ] it makes the ticker
stop or you know the classic old [ __ ]
middle-aged man injury the [ __ ] blown
out Achilles you know oh did you say you
wanted pickles you just turn a little
too
fasten pile that [ __ ] goes right up the
back of your leg then you faceplant
right into your [ __ ] grill side of
the face ah right you be surprised I bet
if I could somehow get some sort of live
you know phoners in here I bet my phone
lines would be lighting up right now
with paramedics Fire Department people
people that drive ambulances is it
driver of the ambulance do you actually
have to know how to help people or you
just like the guy the getaway driver you
know all you need to do is know how to
turn on the siren you know be able to
block it out do you think ambulance
drivers hear that siren at night is a
lay the quiet bedroom you know private
to put [ __ ] music on cuz they don't
they just laying then all is slowly
going insane um I don't know I'm in a
great [ __ ] mood you know my lovely
little lay is starting to sleep through
the night I'm starting to get some sleep
again through cheese hilarious she just
does this thing now she's trying out a
voice she just got loud as [ __ ] laying
in the bed in the morning between me and
they're just that like [ __ ] a little
mini Jerry Lewis class the entire time
it's so I just put my hand over on my
Laingsburg I just make it go like a lot
I think and then she kind of like looks
around like what the [ __ ] was that and
that stops her for about four seconds
before she starts again and then she
gets used to the noise and then that's
it
she's starting to crawl she's [ __ ]
moving backwards it's funny like they
guess they move backwards first so it's
like the thing that they want it just
keeps getting further and further away
like that Alfred Hitchcock shot but uh
anyways I had family from back east out
here this weekend which means plenty of
booze plenty of [ __ ] crazy food so
I've been doing the elliptical every day
doing what I can but uh you know this is
like at this point everybody's going to
come out here has come out here they've
all seen her they all love her
and what's awesome is now I don't have
to I realize now when people visit me
they're not coming to see me which is
[ __ ] awesome
they're coming to see her oh hey Bill
how you doing where is she where is she
she overall would you look at her look
at that's great and you just peel off in
the back you know all your family
members come over then they all get to
hold her and stuff you know so then you
get to sit there boozing in the corner
[Laughter]
happy holidays
no it's been great she's awesome she's
so awesome I'm not getting any [ __ ]
material out of it everyone was telling
you oh my god you having a kid I can't
wait for you to become a dad oh my god I
want to see how your RAC changes it
hasn't I'm still paranoid I'm still
filthy and my daughter is awesome so you
know that's not funny hey Bo it's like
being a dad it's great it's phenomenal I
think most my materials just about other
[ __ ] lunatic parents I'm telling you
what I'm gonna start saying to people
when they go oh yeah that's a great age
you know wait wait till three days from
now
then all well you'll go she's gonna talk
she'll [ __ ] start stabbing you in the
night I'm you know I'm gonna start
saying those parents I'm just gonna be
like you know you sound like a horrible
father and I think you married the wrong
person have a nice day how you could
look at this experience in a negative
way is [ __ ] look if you broke you're
a kid if you're a [ __ ] high school
student right and you know you started
banging your goddamn English teacher
you didn't know enough to pull out as
much as they told you in sex education
how much you know how a baby's made you
couldn't [ __ ] believe you were
banging your English teacher and then
next thing you know you're gonna be your
fault
yeah then Dennis brutal you know you're
married in this [ __ ] old broad who's
always correcting your [ __ ] sentences
you know you're calling around for
dressing like a [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
giving you [ __ ] for a far Daniel in
participle whatever the [ __ ]
never knew what that meant the past
participle but what's the past
participle of this sentence I don't know
just send me to summer school
just give me get me in that [ __ ]
distilled version of this class that is
nothing that dream team of class clowns
that his summer school drug addicts and
musicians it was just [ __ ] tremendous
summer school underrated I tell you I
went I did it twice I should have done
it all four years of high school but I
blew off the last year because what was
the [ __ ] point my sophomore year my
teacher hooked me up gave me the D - D -
in geometry I [ __ ] had a great time I
had a great time I had to take one class
you know got me out of bed in the
morning in summer school was combined
like three towns where I lived and it
was about was all the class clowns just
like I said creative people everybody
had a D D in the level of [ __ ] that they
gave to the teacher I was like why I
gotta up my game
these people aren't a whole nother level
it's like when you go to jail you become
like a better criminal I became a better
class clown just sitting there like wow
these guys are [ __ ] these guys have
no intention to go into college I'm at
least a lie to myself yeah I think I
could you know I think I could go in the
later rounds if you were a [ __ ] draft
pick be honest with yourself you're a
high school student what round are you
going and you know and if you really
think about it that's why Bill Belichick
he doesn't like the first round draft
picks cuz the first round draft picks
they're like book smart right they're
the [ __ ] nerds you know you give them
some information they'll memorize it and
they'll spit it right back at you right
there's no passion they they don't walk
into a room and light it up this is a
bad analogy
cuz first-round draft picks do I guess
do they I don't know about college
basketball now with everybody one and
done you bring this [ __ ] kid to a
locker room full of men and put the team
on his back bony [ __ ] legs
[Music]
Oh bill what are they supposed to do a
lot of them you know it's it's like
their mothers you know they need a new
kidney and and the the shack they live
in is falling okay fair enough fair
enough you know but selfishly as a fan
you know you missed the days and
somebody had four years with [ __ ]
Coach K uh Dean Smith rest his soul
Bobby Knight flipping him in the chin
stop looking down the very bottom there
every I've told that if we ever tell you
much I [ __ ] love that Bobby Knight
speech where he says you know I'm not
gonna you're not good I'm not gonna walk
around with a 14 or 20 I don't know what
it is about that guy I listened to that
speech and it makes me want to go
[ __ ] I don't know I'll go to the gym
after listening to that guy something
happened you know when that guy got ran
out of town that was that was it you
know then all of a sudden like guys
steered into just literally being
[ __ ] like [ __ ] wearing shirts with
cats on them and stuff you know my wife
was showing me that lit there's a men's
onesie that's out there now the guys are
wearing I was like you got to be [ __ ]
kidding like what is it going to start
when is it going to steer back to
testosterone when is the guys guy go to
make a comeback I mean everything makes
a comeback right
classic rock disco hair medals make it a
little bit of a comeback I don't [ __ ]
me I you know I just don't get it so
then somebody show me well they like
well Sean Connery wore one in one of the
James Bond movies and it's like alright
but he wasn't wearing it like he thought
it looked good
he wasn't wearing it cuz it was [ __ ]
stupid you know that's what I can't
[ __ ] stand everything's like mocking
something else it's like alright so what
do you believe it what are you going to
[ __ ] sign your name to and these
[ __ ] millennial [ __ ] big deal I
can't say all of them that's not fair to
a whole generation but so the ones that
the least they've taken pictures of okay
which granted most of these pictures are
being taken care take
by older people from my generation who
are jealous of younger people that's
what a lot of it is I bet I bet I'm
overreacting when I really think about
it I don't really see a lot of people
with cats on their shirts although when
they do people take pictures of them
then they post them on social media and
then old [ __ ] like me start going oh
look at these [ __ ] Millennials daddy
[ __ ] it's a scratch all of it I mean
really bill have you seen anybody with
the onesie somebody just showed you a
picture and then you you literally
started freaking out like you watched
CNN or Fox News for two hours that's
always a great thing to do watch those
for a couple to three hours they get you
all panicked what you want to do is you
want to switch between the two of them
right and then you balance out the lies
and you keep yourself level-headed you
know fake news tell fake news so anyways
I don't be like that I want to be that
guy okay god bless you Millennials I'm
sure this there's plenty of guys guys on
the way you're out there [ __ ] crush
and ass and god bless you joy your youth
joy you [ __ ] Youth before it's
Memorial Day and suddenly you're that
guy with the dad bod standing in front
of the grill feeling that tightness in
your Achilles you know you got to reach
for that last burger on the back of the
[ __ ] grill you just start feeling
that tightness in your ankle you're like
god if it's going to happen please don't
let it happen now not in front of my
family banished
nobody has guessed the movie by the way
that I am referring to we had problems
with the family back aged this I was
going to say I'd give you a hint but
this isn't really him I'm in my opinion
that movie it's a car movie for me I
just feel like that movies a car movie
other people thought there was some
philosophical question you know who's
the fly
who's the windshield all I remember from
that movie was I love the car because I
love a [ __ ] sling
ah I remember the car that was a sleeper
and then I just remembered that there
was this one guy was having problems
with the family back east and that
explained his entire [ __ ] backstory
that's now if you guys can't guess it
now I don't know what the [ __ ] I don't I
don't know what to tell you all right
they had a [ __ ] pizza parlor yeah can
I get a guy get a sausage in arugula and
we got no Rugal you know I mean roogle
yeah we had very we pull up to the
family back east it will give us a rugal
um anyway so what'd you guys do this
weekend other than sit around you know
what I did I watched somebody tweeted me
on the old Twitter and told me are you
watching the time trials for Monaco and
it's a thing I you know I'm new to f1
you guys know I can barely remember the
[ __ ] names so I'm like I'm no idea
like how they qualify for a race I just
thought you'd you know you get like five
laps around the track whoever has the
best time gets the pole position and
then they just work their way back but
that that is not how it works it's like
a whole other day of racing because I
was wondering why the [ __ ] two people
show up to watch these these qualifying
Remi just watch some guy by himself out
there yeah yeah yeah he's got to be an
eighth place tomorrow that's not how it
works
it is the race before the race and it's
like this three race so there's three
levels of the qualifying there's like
first of all this practice laps get you
used to the track and if you don't do
the practice laps you're not allowed to
race so obviously there's probably some
safety thing like dude you're not just
going to [ __ ] and go out there and start
driving 200 miles an hour if this next
one a right or a left turn sham
[Music]
qualifying okay so there's this like
three rounds of it so qualifying the
first round one it's like much madness
but with God
it lasts for 18 minutes everybody gets
on the [ __ ] track I'm sure they I
don't know if they'd let six out then
another six I don't how the [ __ ] they do
it I missed that part of it okay but it
lasts for 18 minutes at the end of which
time can you tell them reading this the
six slowest drivers are eliminated from
qualifying and 16 advance to QT the
qualifying two so those six are going to
be then I thought oh my god are they out
of the [ __ ] race is this like golf
will you miss the cut and I found out
later no they just start way in the back
okay so um so there's 22 [ __ ] drivers
I guess so let's see so six of them are
[ __ ] eliminated they're not they're
usually 20 drivers to to not have to go
home I have no idea if anybody knows the
information to that I don't know if
anybody if you don't move to the next
round of qualifying if anybody actually
doesn't get to race because I thought
there was 20 cars in the race and
according to this mess there's 22 but
whatever so six are eliminated in the
first one then the next 16 you know
after a short break the times are reset
and the 16 remaining cars run in a
fifteen minute session so now we're down
to 15 and at the end of which the
slowest six cars are eliminated from
qualifying leaving 10 to progress to
qualifying 3 now the top 10 spots after
the race those that's when you're in the
points from first all the way to 10th
it's like something like 25 points for
first 18 for second then it's like 15
then 12 10 8 6 4 2 1 other points huh
you're in the you're in the [ __ ]
lightning round at that point and then
whoever obviously has the best run after
that gets the qualifying 3 after a
further break times a reset in the final
12 minutes session is held to decide
pole position in the standing order of
the top 10 grid places that's when
you're in the points
alright that's when you're going home at
least with the [ __ ] year's supply of
rice-a-roni
if you're in the top 10 so I watched it
cuz somebody on Twitter is like dude you
gotta watch this this might be better
than the race so Lewis Hamilton from the
Isle of Man it's an island with men
nothing but men all walking around like
right where the Falken like the birds
whatever the [ __ ] they call him over
there slags anyways he's out there he's
got Mercedes he's got one of the fastest
[ __ ] cars out there but for whatever
[ __ ] reason he's not getting enough
downward force or something on the front
of his car and the front end is sliding
all over everywhere so he barely gets
out of qualifying one he gets into
qualifying two and it's there's a
fifteen minute session and he's outside
of the qualifying to get to the next
level his time is too slow so he's got
time to do one more run okay now he's in
second place overall for the for the to
become chimp to Stan to stay on pace to
be whatever the [ __ ] best drive of
the year I'm sorry guys I'm new to this
[ __ ] thing and his [ __ ] front end
starts sliding all over the place and
then some [ __ ] hits the wall so then the
yellow flag comes out I guess that
doesn't matter if some [ __ ] drives
into the [ __ ] wall your qualifying
time is done this [ __ ] idiot he's a
professional driver he hits the wall I'm
outta here at the wall I get it your
call you know they said they actually
put some special steering in they make
custom steering just for that [ __ ]
track in Monaco cuz they're just driving
through the streets and they have such a
hairpin turn that they actually have to
turn the wheel harder than they do any
other race you know why would they just
leave that in wouldn't you want to have
that option in case you had to drive a
little all the way around something at
some point and the other races evidently
not so anyways long story short this
[ __ ] guy I think from Force India
with the fuchsia car just basically you
know he pulls the Greg Bay Brady you
know got to beat Marcia getting a cool
closer than a quarter of an inch he
[ __ ] slams right into the wall
and then that's it and Lewis Hamilton
was so [ __ ] dejected he couldn't even
get out of his car you know and long
story short the [ __ ] Ferraris what a
[ __ ] is my goddamn computer keep doing
this to me trying to get the screen to
come up and you stay up dog I said to
have finger in the [ __ ] thing the
whole time yes a long story short the
Ferraris won the first in second
position and I think that boot toss guy
the finish dude started in third and
Lewis Hamilton was all the way back in
14th so he's out of the points and
you're driving through the [ __ ]
streets of Monaco a sovereign state in
other words they're in France but
they're not part of France like yeah
[ __ ] off we're doing our own thing here
and I guess it's really hard to pass
there but despite that the [ __ ] race
starts and immediately he went from 14th
to 12th and I'm watching the race and
I'm like this [ __ ] he's probably
going to finish fourth he's somehow
going to figure somebody's going to [ __ ]
up and that pit stop something's going
to happen so I'm one the whole time I'm
watching the race and I'm watching that
he's 12th then he's 11 then he's 10th
and the [ __ ] announcers are blowing
it off because they're too busy looking
at the what the Ferraris are going to do
what the Red Bull teams doing what the
[ __ ]
boo toss is going to be doing in the
Mercedes it meanwhile he is Lewis
Hamilton just moving up this is the
longest ever talked about racing Alec
they got a feeling people like dude I
don't give a [ __ ]
around a circle um no they're not then I
try around there's left and right turns
alright
this is chicane dude Uli's got a watch
monocle you should have watched Monaco
with a [ __ ] Illuminati people [ __ ]
back their yachts up although I went
online and I found like you can actually
there's a lot of them are just like
packages like those aren't just rich
people with a yachts backed up it's just
a lot of like booze cruises and you can
sit there on a [ __ ] yacht getting
hammered acting like you didn't just
light up your [ __ ] credit card
whatever Stacey we'll deal with it when
we get back we get baggy shhhhht so long
story short on a track that you could
not [ __ ] pass on somehow lewis passed
seven [ __ ] people finish seventh so
let's see that's one two he got like six
points or something like that and the
Ferraris came in first and second all
right
sebastian vettel ended up winning after
a great [ __ ] pit stop and
what's-his-face Kimi räikkönen is that
his [ __ ] name raking in and whatever
finish dude Sebastian's the kraut the
German dude he [ __ ] comes out of the
pit before me hit Kimi going like God
what the [ __ ] he sounded like me would
somebody cut me off for traffic but he's
driving like 170 miles an hour uh then
what's his face Daniel always a
bridesmaid never a [ __ ] winner
Ricardo came in [ __ ] third the guys
always on the podium never comes in
first he's got to be pissed like guys
what the [ __ ] can you do something to
the car here so I get past these
Ferraris and Mercedes I'm a hello and I
got to do here so long story short
Ferrari as a team has 196 points
Mercedes has 179 and the Americans the
Yanks just to let you know we're pulling
up the rear we got our first points of
the season
what do we got we got Romain like the
lettuce gross Jean he got nine points
and then Kevin Magnussen like the
condoms got five so we got fourteen
points so just those Ferraris and
Mercedes better mind their [ __ ] P's
and Q's because the Yanks are coming all
right thank you for [ __ ] sitting
through all that
[ __ ] let's talk about Tiger Woods Jesus
[ __ ] Christ can you believe he got
arrested for drinking and driving it
only happens to nine million people
every [ __ ] day I'm so sick of people
talking about Tiger Woods like the way
they disrespect this guy you know I love
Steven Naismith but I started watching
him talking and he was saying that you
know that you know this guy's just his
fall from basically his fall from grace
and inau his whole you know he became a
billionaire and his whole [ __ ] thing
was based on the fact that he presented
himself as a family man and I'm thinking
like what when the [ __ ] did he ever
present himself as a family man didn't
he get to where the [ __ ] he was because
he was the best golf or anybody had ever
seen because he was making like PG a
[ __ ] links look like like he was
playing miniature golf I don't pay
attention to that [ __ ] blonde he was
why don't even to a [ __ ] name then a
low so he bangs a bunch of Hooters
[ __ ] and then I'm then I'm supposed to
sit on the couch going he lied to me
Tiger I thought after your golf you
[ __ ] went down to Applebee's with
your family and [ __ ] your family
baggies and you shared a [ __ ] bloomin
onion I have to be honest with you I
never once thought about what the [ __ ]
that guy did when he got off the golf
course and when I found out what he was
doing off the golf course I was like
yeah I mean that kind of makes sense I'm
just saying it's the amount of [ __ ]
men okay when Steven a Smith walks out
of his studio you know he doesn't have a
line of [ __ ] just waiting to [ __ ]
blow him just so they could say I blew
Steven a Smith Tiger Woods had to deal
with that and like most men he folded
under the pressure
and the [ __ ] reason why he's not
doing well right now it's not because of
his [ __ ] wife who by the way took a
bunch of his money bought a house
[ __ ] knocked it down and then rebuilt
another one huh what about her I thought
she was right what about her what about
old blondie right there I still a bit
about this do you think she would even
give Tiger Woods a second [ __ ] glance
if he wasn't making all that money if he
wasn't the greatest at what he did would
old blond blue-eyed even give that guy a
[ __ ] second I don't think she would
have all right even when you're a bum
like me when you [ __ ] walked in the
singles bar back in the 90s what did
women always say what do you do they're
not making small talk okay women all
[ __ ] judge okay their status and then
they get a number in their head all
right and then they find out the jobs
okay that earn this and earn that and
then they figure it like who they can
[ __ ] okay and then it becomes a thing of
like okay you're underneath what I want
for the lifestyle that I'm looking for
in the future
but you're a good-looking enough guy
that I'll [ __ ] bang it tonight maybe
I'll have a little fling with you but
that's good at the end of the [ __ ]
day you know when you slid that piece of
paper across the table and you made your
offers say my dick and balls bring home
this each year they're like yeah keep it
moving keep it moving that's that's 10
grand less than I want and you got that
one snaggletooth [ __ ] off move on who's
next go ahead put your junk on the table
what's your number it is it's a thing I
don't fault women for that who wants to
live like a bum if you're good and if
you're good-looking enough okay and you
can land somebody that's making a ton of
[ __ ] money you can learn to love that
right I don't know so anyway so now he
gets busted for drinking and driving in
that this is the bottom line this
[ __ ] guy's fall from grace okay all
right I'll give you the first [ __ ]
couple of years after his divorce like
maybe that got in his [ __ ] head but
at the end of them you get divorced ten
[ __ ] years ago what happened was was
his marriage and his body broke down at
the same [ __ ] time but I just had
major back surgeries knees are [ __ ] up
and they always said they said back when
everybody thought he was a family man
back east that the way that the level of
torque and the pressure they was putting
on his back they predicted his body was
going to break down and it did and then
when it does you know now they're going
to blame you know it's the classic
lady's just taking credit that's all it
is they always take her behind you every
great man is a good woman
you know they okay or is it I don't I
mean what's your definition of great I
mean but every great man is a great
woman it's like the guy was already a
[ __ ] champion when he met you so if
you're talking about his mother I'll
give you that but this whole [ __ ]
thing well now I mean Jesus I got to
tell you his mug shot oh that's a
classic one I'd like to have a couple of
pops with Tiger always yet he needs this
is what he needs to do he needs to hit
the [ __ ] treadmill all right and he's
got to shave his [ __ ] head already
you got to let that go you know all God
he comes to Monday morning it comes to
MMP Photoshop can you please photoshop
my [ __ ] head underneath
Tiger Woods his [ __ ] hair
oh god you know what's funny is he looks
like he's [ __ ] wasted but you know
what he's saying he's looking into the
camera going well I know a billion
people are going to see this what the
[ __ ] are they gonna say about this one I
don't I can't even begin to tell you
guys I can't can't begin to tell you
guys how bad
see this guy win a major again look at
this editor's pick this secret history
of Tiger Woods now how much do you think
they actually talked to Tiger Woods so
the death of his father set a battle
raging inside the world's greatest
golfer
dish dish how the [ __ ] do you know why
cuz you talked to his gardener said the
closest you could get to him and I gonna
write 400 pages of [ __ ] listen do me
a favor don't listen to any of this
stuff okay he's a man he makes mistakes
he's in the public eye I hope his back
gets better you know what I hope he goes
out like [ __ ] who's that guy used to
[ __ ] just sit there the big dude up
with the blonde hair and he's [ __ ] sit
there I think he played Oliver on the
Brady Bunch way back in the day then
when he grew up he became this drunk he
was this alcoholic [ __ ] he could hit
the ball a [ __ ] mile out goddamn it
he's gonna kill me I can look this up
here alcoholic
golfer driver long that's how I searched
and John Daly there we go BAM nailed it
John you know I hope he comes back like
a combination like I don't know
Terminator and John Daly that's what I
want I want a [ __ ] drunk cyborg going
out there and I hope he [ __ ] passes
Jack Nicholas and just you know I don't
understand people that look at people in
the public eye to the point that they
disappoint them
you know get a [ __ ] life Jesus Christ
what there was that [ __ ] movie got
Captain Kirk when he did they did this
sketch talking to the Trekkies on SNL
get a [ __ ] life you know guys I don't
know I don't know if you notice the last
couple weeks I've been a little uh I
know I've been a little down you know
and I know the podcast hasn't been as
good as it has been in the past and it's
just cuz uh you know
I feel like Tiger Woods let me down you
know all those times I've never met him
or even remotely spoken to him you know
I just really thought we had something
there and for him to turn around and go
back on his word that he never gave me
because I've never spoken with the mat
just I was devastated and I'm not going
to be able to come into work today oh
man I hope that guy wins another [ __ ]
major
I can't even tell you I can't I can't
even [ __ ] I just did tell you didn't
I I think I just did tell you um hey
last week I was talking about
helicopters and uh you know I know some
pilots listen to this [ __ ] thing you
know mass bumping I'll let you have to
deal with Logie pushover with the
[ __ ] semi articulated rotor system
does anybody know about these [ __ ]
these new european helicopters that are
starting to be available over here and
has a fully articulated rotor system so
you have to deal with any of that [ __ ]
and if you'll inject it to this no do I
need to pull carb heat am I gonna
[ __ ] die here
it's called I don't have to say GUI MB
al guy humble Gabry g2 and I wrote next
to it once the deal I talked to two of
my instructors one of them said hey
that's pretty cool that they do then the
other one said well it's kind of like
remember when the first iPhone came out
because they're brand new then they had
to work all the bugs out
he said they learned about aircraft
through people crashing that's oddly I
[ __ ] those things then um anyways you
know you don't think I'm one of these
days what I'm going to do is I'm just
gonna buy a used Apache you know or
whatever the [ __ ] they have those
Blackhawks is some [ __ ] I'm just gonna
learn how to fly that and then I'm just
gonna join those black water dudes
that's my apocalypse thing you know what
I mean I'm not gonna learn how to kill
people I think like that I'll just be
the shuttle guy I'll take you back from
the front lines back to base base camp
and I'll just sit there eating my soup
that's my game plan alright let's read
some of the [ __ ] advertising here for
this week which of course I didn't even
did I even look this [ __ ] up yet no I
didn't I apologize for this
you know I just it's just Tiger Woods
let me down you know I thought he was a
family member and uh I mean I haven't
been this [ __ ] I haven't been this
[ __ ] distraught since uh Michael
Jordan's acceptance speech at the Hall
of Fame when I found out who he really
was I mean I was devastated and I just
remember all those times I had not hung
out with Michael Jordan ever talked to
him I just feel like he really just you
know I just thought he was better than
that I loved that when he gave that
speech and ever he's like wait a minute
this guy's like [ __ ] got ice water in
his veins and he's got a mean streak in
him it's like yeah yeah all those
[ __ ] people who were never picked in
gym class they were like oh this is why
I sucked it wasn't just that I was
uncoordinated I didn't have this killer
[ __ ] instinct he went after his own
goddamn kids you know and that's what it
takes all right me undiano me on DS
biondi's Michael Jordan's [ __ ] long
shorts to do to me on DS me undies did
that long because of his dork
he's [ __ ] six six so is his dick but
his balls were rough until he got me on
DS and then he made the Hall of Fame he
finally beat the [ __ ] Pistons because
his piston was nice and [ __ ] soft
with me on DS what about Bill Walton all
right pride starts on the inside so
celebrate yourself with me undies me
undies makes the ultimate feel-good
undies with Free Shipping right to your
door satisfaction guaranteed all
designed in LA Louisiana Los Angeles
every pair of me undies is made with
micro motile Modell a fabric three times
softer than cotton you know it's true
because you have never heard the cotton
lobby ever debated their soft stretchy
undies come in every ever-changing array
of colors and patterns no matter what
your style they got something for you
that's because the undies believes in
people feeling good and being themselves
which is why me undies won't
my own DS is putting their money where
their underwear is during Pride Month
for every pair of special edition
celebrate undies you buy during pride me
undies drink pride sorry me undies will
donate $1 to the Los Angeles LGBT Center
ah you fear pandering to your audience
you got a bunch of colorful underwear
right I'd see what's going on you get
did a little algorithm well more gay
people than straights up buying these
you know we go maybe we gotta Glenn
maybe gay people buy the gay people gay
guys I bet gay guys buy more underwear
more underwear than straight guys do you
know because women are so [ __ ]
forgiving right but guys is so visual
so maybe gay guys like I just feel a
pressure that I always have to have new
underwear on because I just feel such I
just feel like for me when somebody sees
my dick and balls first I want to have a
brand new pair of me undies good for
them good for them I bet if you look
that up I bet that's true
generally speaking gay men have newer
cleaner underwear than a straight guy
right anyways as if you needed another
reason to try me undies they're offering
20% off your first pair and a
satisfaction guarantee that you'll
you'll love them are your money back
just visit our URL URL
me undies dot-com / / head to me undies
today and pick up a pair of special
editions celebrate undies you'll not
only get a discount of awesome undies
you'll be donating to an amazing cause
check out my undies dot-com slash birth
today I want to know when you're going
to come out with the caitlyn jenner's
you know you guys ought to do it like a
like how basketball sneakers do they'll
pick like you know they got Jordans they
got the Kobe's you know and after that
game 7 you know you know what's coming
out next October the Olynyk ones every
white guy with the dreams going to be
buying those they ought to do that with
me undies you know you ought to have the
tiger woods' tiger woods' me undies the
caitlyn jenner's who else's be a good
person to [ __ ]
money up with Ric Flair's you got to get
the Ric Flair's telling it's a whole new
market for you guys alright blue apron
not only not okay not all ingredients
are created equal well Jesus Christ
thick [ __ ] donors they're making America
great again once not all ingredients I
created equally yeah fresh high quality
ingredients make a real difference oh
really
fresh high quality ingredients make a
real difference when you're cooking oh I
could just pull some out of the trash
these blue apron guys you're always
learning something anyways it's
important to know where your food comes
from really I just I just thought I
could keep eating [ __ ] cows that were
fed other cows talk about your personal
experience with blue apron I've never
used it additional copy points feature
as desired okay this is all this is all
optional well I'll go right to the end
then blue apron a better way to cook and
I can't do that alright additional
cooking affordable ok for all you people
upside down in your house out there you
know and nobody gives a [ __ ] you still
want to eat well for less than $10 per
person per meal blue apron delivers
seasonal recipes along with pre portion
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals variety choose from a
variety here variety if you don't want
to come home to the same [ __ ] mashed
potatoes and every once in a while you
want to have a little [ __ ] of a girl
ruin okay for less than $10 per person
per meal
sorry it's Roma choose from a variety of
new recipes each week oh let blue aprons
culinary team surprise you holy [ __ ]
recipes are not repeated within a year
so you'll never get bored
guaranteed blue aprons freshness
guarantees promise that every ingredient
and your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right check out this
week's menu and get the first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron com / / blue apron
dot-com / / blue apron a better way to
cook
and lastly but certainly not least Lia
Dollar Shave Club look at them with a
nice [ __ ] quick copy they understand
they understand my difficulties Dollar
Shave Club is the smart choice you'll
get a great shave and a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door they have all the jerseys they have
the steel is the Shaq's the charges and
more sorry that was the voice I was just
remember from MVP sports that read from
way back in the day when they didn't
want to hire somebody professional they
just hired some [ __ ] hot chick that
the owner was probably banging like
Tiger Woods but he hasn't won a golf
tournament so nobody knows right anyways
you no longer have to schlep to the
store buy a cheap disposable [ __ ]
wraith that gives you a buy educate what
you no longer have to schlep to the
store to buy a cheap disposable razor
that gave you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on razors with gimmickry shaving
technologies you didn't need and when
you use Doc Dollar Shave club's
executive razor with the doctor caddy
blade gently glides giving you a smooth
shave dr. carver shea butter is
transparent for a more precise shave
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps make the smarter choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club do you know
the people at Dollar Shave Club had a
custom doctor cavies easy shave bought a
tube that they framed Andrew finally was
able to convince me to take the thing
because they gave you something I'm like
I don't want anymore [ __ ] I got too much
[ __ ] and he goes now you got to see this
thing and like [ __ ] a year later I
finally got it from him and like god
dammit that's another thing I got to put
up on the wall and someday explain to
people oh I have mild dyslexia and I
thought dr. Carver shea butter said dr.
Carver Ezz shea butter and I used to
scream it and it's like GTL do you have
any more boring stories framed on your
wall yes yes I do okay make the smarter
choice by joining Dollar Shave Club for
a limited time new members can get their
first month of the executive razor with
a tube of their doctor can have easy
for only five dollars with free shipping
after that
razors are just a few bucks a month
that's a 15 dollar value for only five
bucks then no hidden fees no commitments
cancel anytime you like you can only get
this offer exclusively at dr.
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bur all right 44
minutes in just like that okay all right
let's read these [ __ ] let's read
these [ __ ] questions here all right
Europe hi that's it I like it short and
sweet been a huge fan of Bill for many
years are there any plans for touring
Europe specifically the Netherlands
would love to see him perform live well
I was there last year man if you were
fan for many years you should have
checked my website I think I'm going to
go to Europe next year and I'll probably
build it around a couple of f1 races
possibly I don't know what when I'm
going to go over there but I'm
definitely due to do a run I got a bunch
of new [ __ ] but you know I have to make
sure it's at a certain level before I go
over there coz Europe you loves to just
have critics show up it shows without
you know the artist saying hey can you
review this show you know and they
review it anyway and they take out their
[ __ ] goddamn steak knives and they
carve you up every [ __ ] time so I
always make sure I'm on my game here all
right girl who stabbed boyfriend isn't
walking free okay here we go
this is the new this is new part of the
podcast everybody [ __ ] correct an old
bill you know that's why I made sure to
[ __ ] like look up all my my f1 [ __ ]
you know cuz you caught damn [ __ ] girl
who stabbed boyfriend I have a
prediction about the Red Sox too by the
way which I will get to later on
hopefully if I remember all right that's
a teaser and I might let you down I
might disappoint you like Michael Jordan
like [ __ ] Tiger Woods you know all
that entertainment that they gave you
when they watched when you get to watch
them doing things that have never been
done before alright girl who stabbed
boyfriend isn't walking free okay so
this story was about
lady in Oxford - [ __ ] I don't know
what the hell she did she stabbed her
boyfriend in the leg with the bread
knife and blah blah blah blah blah and
the thing guy was like well I don't you
you have you know you have all this
[ __ ] you know potential and all this
type of [ __ ] so this person this person
is writing back saying she isn't going
free what so I realize you like to make
the excuse that we shouldn't expect you
to do any actual research on story as
you talked about and that's fine well
then you should leave it at that sir but
in this particular story you ranted on
Thursdays Park I didn't rant I'm joking
around you [ __ ] overreacting [ __ ] do
you guys understand what a rant is rant
to me is short for ranting and raving so
you got a borderline have froth coming
out of your [ __ ] mouth joking around
about a subject for five minutes it's
not a [ __ ] rant you stupid [ __ ] god
damnit alright so even like right there
to me that's just so I just [ __ ]
[ __ ] wigged out for a second there
but I hear a rant it okay on Thursday
you didn't even you didn't even need to
do research to see how wrong you were
again I'm not wrong I'm being funny you
[ __ ] that Oxford girl isn't getting off
free because she's white oh my god as
the lovely Nia proposed and not because
she's a woman as the frekin be literate
burr suggested she isn't getting off at
all in fact it said right on the article
you were reading that she was going to
be sentenced in September and has been
giving a restraining order yeah I saw
that
and I also read the [ __ ] judges quote
I looked it up and I read along with
your podcast her sentencing was only
postponed she isn't getting out of jail
time yet yeah but don't you find it
[ __ ] up would even address the fact
that the judge said you're so talented I
don't want to derail your [ __ ] what
you could possibly achieve you don't
think that's weird for him to say that
and you don't think race and gender
affects
your sentencing you don't think that you
don't think that any day that there's
all this racism there's all this sexism
and all that but in the court of law
there isn't there isn't status there
isn't you're at Oxford versus you're
just somebody on the street you stab
somebody with the [ __ ] knife you
don't think that any that comes into
play sir so anyways he says if you ask
me which you didn't I think this is a
good thing if she is as bright as the
people at the school say she is she can
definitely do a lot of good in her
career and sentencing her for a one-off
would ruin that so you're agreeing with
this guy oh my god this is [ __ ]
hilarious you sitting here saying that
I'm not paying that's basically what it
is is not that I was misinformed okay
it's that you agreed with the judge he
said that being said she needs to be
held responsible so what is it seeing as
if it was only a butter knife
I think mandatory anger-management
classes is an order at the very least
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself come back to
Medicine you were great last time go
[ __ ] yourself again sir she stabbed
somebody with a knife
let me let that sink in she stabs
someone with a [ __ ] knife but because
she goes to Oxford and she could be a
doctor yeah you're out of your [ __ ]
mind you're just like the judge you're
like oh look at her she's a girl she's
doing so well in school she looks like
me it was just a bread knife you're
doing what they're doing in a perfect
world sir stabbing somebody with a knife
and the punishment is stabbing something
with a knife in the punishment and
that's [ __ ] it go watch that [ __ ]
trap car thing or whatever the [ __ ] they
call it will they park it down in the
[ __ ] poor neighbour and they arrest
one black eye after a [ __ ] another I
mean it's they're not trying to help
anybody you don't think anybody down
there has potential you're just going to
see it's going to [ __ ] do that to
them
why do they just do why they don't why
don't they do that in a [ __ ] white
neighborhood oh my god I don't know I
don't I just don't see the world the way
you do sir and you see it the way that
judge does and I also think that you are
like what you're taking into
consideration which is is the fact that
she's at Oxford she could be a doctor
you're completely in you're now
downplaying that she stabs someone and
yes you are sir yes you are because you
said she should take anger management
classes at the very least look you might
call me [ __ ] overly liberal but if
you stab someone you should go to jail
regardless of what your potential is do
you realise that this woman if she
becomes a surgeon will have a knife in
her hand every [ __ ] day of her
goddamn career just about and it won't
be a [ __ ] butter knife jesus [ __ ]
christ and when she's goes to cut
somebody open and then finds out that
they have state insurance rather than
private what the [ __ ] is she going to do
then just because you go to Oxford
doesn't mean you couldn't be a [ __ ]
lunatic you don't I mean and people in
those schools commit murders and they do
commit crimes but they don't go to jail
the way poorer people with more of a tan
do I don't know if you've noticed that
so for us to bring up the fact that she
was a woman and that she was white I was
not
we were not uninformed we're actually
Morton I actually you know I'm gonna Pat
myself on the back I'm more [ __ ]
enlightened than you are okay cuz I'm
not saying that because of who she is
she should get punished more she should
get the punishment I think once you stab
somebody what the [ __ ] you're doing in
the rest of your life is out the goddamn
window and I know you guys gonna say
when they do that they do that all the
time they [ __ ] take into
consideration if people have children
and bla bla bla bla yeah I know they do
but the consideration is is a lot
smaller by the level of tan you have and
whether you have a dick hanging between
your legs and not and that's the [ __ ]
truth go into a bar a woman can slap
in the face dump a drink over his
[ __ ] head she's not getting kicked
out she's not if she's if she's hot
she's a [ __ ] wildebeest yeah they'll
throw her out in the [ __ ] dumpster
come on people this isn't this isn't new
information all right stop acting like
good lord
all right why Airlines lost their
privilege now hey Bill big fan love your
podcast you recently asked why airlines
are not as prestigious as it was in the
70s as a pilot I have an answer for you
oh I love when the pilots write in sky
why isn't it's still gray in 1978 huh
I'm Jimmy Cohn Jimmy Carter signed the
airline deregulation Act I'll leave it
to a peanut farmer from Georgia to ruin
the [ __ ] prestige of airline train
travel prior to this law the government
allowed equal usage of federal Airways
among all the airlines all right you
already lost me we read this Laura the
government allowed equal usage of
federal airwaves among all airlines so
the only way for airlines to compete
effectively was with good customer
service okay after the law went into
effect airlines were able to bid for
exclusive usage of certain airwaves
Airways are basically the streets in the
sky so different okay oh I see so then
and everybody had that territory so it
was like that's right there was Eastern
Airlines they just flew there okay all
right American and United flew cross
country so I was like wrestling back in
the day where everybody had their
territories and then rather than one guy
dominate the whole thing like Vince it
became a bidding war okay after the law
went into effect airlines were able to
bid exclusive usage of certain Airways
so Airways essentially gained monopolies
on most of their routes with customers
having little or no say in which airline
to take the airlines were able to get us
by the balls so now airlines business
strategy has shifted
from good customer service to
monopolizing their Airways and packing
as many people as possible into their
plane planes hope this helps it started
- what should I look up I should look up
the airline deregulation Act now that
all of a sudden in the era of fake news
I'm being suddenly being held
accountable for what the [ __ ] I can't
believe this
you guys are so disappointing me can
somebody please write in and mock these
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright not saying that
the pilot here alright airline
deregulation Act airline deregulation
Act Jimmy Carter and effects let's see
what we got here oh my god
alright Wiki the law that changed the
airline industry that's the one that
looks like ok this is the one I will
read up on are you guys going to try to
make me informed and then I'll didn't
you know what happens when you don't
have to become you informed you become
an arrogant ass you know you start
smoking a pipe you [ __ ] eyebrows are
always trying to touch each other as you
wrinkle up your forehead no one wants to
be around that alright a law that
changed the airline industry beyond
recognition 1978 alright
ok before deregulations airlines
competed on service alone as fares were
regulated by the government I didn't
know that I mean granted I was [ __ ]
ten years old nineteen seventy many
remember this era fondly is the Golden
Age of aviation
when stewardesses as flight attendants
were then known carved I can
Chateaubriand on rolling silver carts
and Airlines put piano lounges and upper
decks at their Boeing 747s passengers
dressed up to board flights and flying
was glamorous and exciting and mainly
for the rich that's why the Liberals
deregulations resulted in the rise of a
new kind of airline the low-cost carrier
LCC at the time of dear
halation Southwest Airline was a small
regional airline prevented by CA B rules
I know what that is from flying outside
of Texas today Southwest is the largest
domestic US carrier in terms of
passenger traffic something no one could
have foreseen in 1978
yeah that's back when stewardesses were
[ __ ] hot so now it's a bunch of
animals they pack us all in and then
it's just like yeah all the hotties like
well [ __ ] this I'm gonna go sell jello
shots at a goddamn one of those DJ shows
wait baby baby right Southwest is a
success story but deregulation allowed
yeah I hate flying Southwest I [ __ ]
hate e you know why I hate how that the
stewardesses sit there making jokes and
[ __ ] around it's like dude my life is
in your hands here you're not making me
more relaxed doing you [ __ ] Dean
Martin impression but deregulation
allowed Airlines to innovate new
business models people people Express I
remember that remember valujet that one
went down people express may have come
and gone it may someday be revived but
it it and others like it shook up the
white glove world of the US airline
industry and democracy's travel hope I
said that right we may peer through our
rose-colored glasses and yearn for the
days of Chateau bring all and piano
lounges but ultimate companies like
Southwest and newer ones like Spirit
allowed more people to fly more often
yeah and now look at the result you got
people with no shoes on walking into the
bathroom oh my god holy [ __ ] do I like
being informed deregulation left the
international carriers like Pan Am and
Braniff and to a lesser extent
TWA Trans World Airlines without robust
domestic feeder networks I don't know
what that means and it allowed domestic
carriers like Delta Airlines to apply
for international routes Pan Am and
Braniff scrambled to create domestic
networks but ultimately were
unsuccessful although it took until 2004
TWA to be absorbed into American
Airlines in some argue that massive
consolidation of the US airline industry
in the last decade which has resulted in
three large carriers for when Southwest
is included is deregulations final act
the network carriers that survive Delta
United and American learned to be tough
competitors and combined existing
domestic networks with the international
networks acquired in large part by
carriers like Pan Am that didn't make it
get the [ __ ] out of it so now they have
to drag people off flights barefooted
lunatics and then you got people [ __ ]
you know you even see those people that
just fly around the world all the time
trying to get miles and [ __ ] just
created all these bottom feeders Wow do
you think of VIP airline would would
make it I wonder you know in this era of
Donald Trump if they just de if they
didn't even try to be nice just be I
wish I wish I could do a trump
impression should be a lot of animals
they flying barefoot not a bear fee and
then you know all the Liberals would be
like you are you saying that barefooted
people shouldn't be allowed to let a
bare feet not a bare feet dude can you
what if won't if they had a [ __ ] you
couldn't do it nowadays if you had a
[ __ ] top-line airline okay all
first-class seats all hot stewardesses
you know first of all all the [ __ ]
you know all the [ __ ] feminists would
be up in arms would all be up in arms
saying that they you're objectifying
these women blah blah blah blah blah and
at the end of the fight oh no I agree
with some of that feminist [ __ ] but a
lot of times I just feel like it's women
who aren't good-looking hating on
good-looking women and just being mad
that good-looking women don't have to
work as hard you know it's like that
whole thing that you're going to somehow
get people to give not as good-looking
women not as good-looking men not as
strong men like a chance that's not how
it works
got it like you got to look at it like
sports and realize that you're not the
Jordan you're not Sidney Crosby all
right you're on the fourth line okay so
what you have to be is you have to be a
[ __ ] you got to be a gamer you know
this is coming from a bald redheaded
male so go [ __ ] yourself if you think
I'm being elitist here okay you got to
be scrappy you got to go in the corners
all right you got to drop the gloves
every once in a while you got to do that
okay you're not going to get the calls
you're going to have to work ten times
[ __ ] harder than other people to get
you know half as much or ever the
expression goes but it'll make you
stronger you know what's great is your
fall from grace from your youth sixth as
you slide into a four is not that bad
but at the end of everybody's life
everybody looks like a four or two okay
but you have a nice soft landing you do
a little bit of a belly flop you get the
wind knocked out of you between 20 and
60 all right these [ __ ] tens I mean
they're falling off the top of a goddamn
building okay then a lot of them they
don't survive it they don't if you look
at the Botox faces they look like they
landed face first if [ __ ] lips are
all swollen I mean Jesus Christ look at
these [ __ ] like Mia watches this show
and these women will not stop taking fat
from the back of their arms and injected
them in their ass and they got these
stupid looking [ __ ] asses now and
their legs look like my legs with this
weird like they look like ostriches I
don't know why they did that I I just I
just don't [ __ ] understand why I get
what point it's like they're literally
like Michael Jackson where Michael
Jackson couldn't see what he's doing to
his face these women cannot see what
they're doing to their asses I don't
understand it so anyways do you know
what that was actually fascinating and I
make fun of the fact that I'm I'm not a
well-read guy because it gives me
license to be lazy and that's what I
like to do best okay but if you [ __ ]
[ __ ] are gonna make me keep reading
I I did I did enjoy that I do enjoy
I like drum [ __ ] I like aviation I like
that type of [ __ ] alright so if you got
a [ __ ]
really start holding my feet to the fire
here could you please try to keep it uh
I don't know well I guess I have the
power right I have the power where I can
actually decide what the [ __ ] it is that
I want to read or what I don't want to
read
speaking of which for some reason I woke
up this morning thinking about Roy
Haynes and the fact that he's still
alive and still doing gigs in all the
[ __ ] people he's played with like I
saw a bunch of great jazz dramas before
they passed I saw Max Roach I saw Tony
Williams
I saw Louie Bellson and I saw Roy Haynes
I tell Roy Haynes like 20-something
years ago when he was in his 70s he's
now 92 and I looked it up like this
guy's still on the road he's got a road
gig coming up in September it's like the
Blue Note in New York City he's from
Roxbury Massachusetts a fellow Boston
guy I'm a suburb guy he's actually in
Boston but um I don't I think that's
pretty [ __ ] cool the guys still
gigging out there when you talk about
guy he played with Charlie Parker Miles
Davis Sarah Vaughan following it all the
way up right up through like young
people today the guy's been playing
drums professionally for 70 goddamn
years so I don't know if you're into
drums you got to go see that guy all
right let me go uh let me read some more
the all right let me read these last two
cultural appropriation dear Billy
rationale things are getting crazy these
days because of Technology it's
definitely a lot easier to be critical
of what everyone does I'm sure you've
experienced this before where people try
and misrepresent what you say for
whatever self-serving reason they may
have yes of course that would be the
Huffington Post one of the things going
on today that really bugs me is the
accusation of cultural appropriation
I hate picking extreme sides to any
arguments so I will say I do think that
there are cases of cultural disrespect
let's say someone wears a religious or
cultural garb and is overly
disrespectful for the purpose of
trolling that could be that could be
appropriation you put that in quotes so
do you not think it is but almost
everything anyone does is derived from
another culture in some respect there is
a YouTube video where a young black
college girl rates a hippie for his
cornrows and it seems a bit silly
because the kid is just doing what every
other wookies who listen to Phish - I
don't know what a wookie is is that
somebody into Chewbacca
now [ __ ] now I got to look this up what
the [ __ ] is a wookie a white something
wookie meaning slang a wookie urban
dictionary a wookie a wookie is a hairy
yet modernized human being that commonly
is seen in the Western in the
westernmost regions of Washington a
gentle creature by nature but tends to
get a little erratic when it overindulge
itself with its favorite foods its diets
consists mainly of a blend of barley and
hops if you see these creatures be
cautious as to whether you should
provide him with these items they will
commonly respond to the name of Richard
Pulliam but be very worried of these
creatures I have no idea they're usually
a member a certain brand of cookie that
is very chewy a wookie is a lifeless
idiot whose whole existence consists of
falling around jam bands here we go and
not showering or shaving when they're
not panhandling and trying to rip people
off their selling veggie burritos or
grilled cheese to fund their useless
existence they stand for nothing and
care about nobody else not to be
confused with a hippie aap is someone
who lives a certain lifestyle due to
their belief fifties often shower and
have jobs used in a sentence shows yell
those wookies over there
are trying to sell beat roles that's
from [ __ ] 2003 so I guess they've
been around for a while okay alright let
me get back to the okay so now I know
what a wookie is any wookie is and I
know about Airline Deregulation and now
going to be insufferable the next [ __ ]
social event as I try to work both of
those into the conversation um where the
[ __ ] is it I was an anthropology major
which doesn't make me an expert but it
definitely informs my opinion of this I
went to culinary school after college
and learned even more about cultures
through their food I came upon this
article and wanted to get your take upon
it take a a couple girls in Portland
Oregon started a food truck selling
Mexican food they traveled around and
learned recipes the way every chef I've
ever known has has done they were
accused of cultural appropriation
because they're not Mexican I'm not
going to go on a tirade of [ __ ]
[ __ ] but my adrenaline really
starts going when I think about this I
haven't heard you speak about cultural
appropriation yet and wanted to get your
take here's a link oh the Huffington
Post what a [ __ ] surprise thanks for
your podcast you're a great dad and
husband how do you know you have no idea
um I hate the [ __ ] Huffington Post um
they're always trying to stir up some
[ __ ] you know I hate all these
organizations that try to act like
they're their news organization and you
read two articles and you know who
everybody on the website voted for
essentially it's like back in the day
like it was supposed to be in a no fewer
journalists she was supposed to just
sort of present what the [ __ ] happened
not making up um if you say this on
that's probably because you're doing
that that's like that whole [ __ ]
website and I shouldn't just single them
off there's a bunch of them out there
and but they're held in like this is
steam I just don't understand it anyways
cultural appropriation is I I don't
[ __ ] know you know look if you have
an appreciation for Mexican food you
learn how to cook it and then you sell
it I think at that point if you become
successful that's when people get
annoyed by it and college kids are
really extreme in their thoughts as I do
you know you're [ __ ] breaking free of
your parents you know and you got some
anger issues probably too
your parents so you're very you're very
open to radical [ __ ] sort of ideas
you know going all the way over here all
the way over there it's a very dangerous
time in your life because you make very
extreme judgment snap judgment calls
with your young brain as I did and that
can cause you to do stupid [ __ ] like
join cults blow yourself up at a [ __ ]
concert you know for some stupid [ __ ]
cause yeah all the way to like I don't
know what [ __ ] without a condom you
know you just pretty [ __ ] wide thing
this is why I don't talk about [ __ ] like
this I don't know what a cultural
appropriation is I don't know what it is
all I know is that my culture is the
matrix so everybody's allowed you know I
don't get upset when people get on
airplanes be a that's a white [ __ ] you
know I would say that if they're two
white girls being white and then making
great [ __ ] Mexican food good for them
but if they're sitting there wearing a
[ __ ] sombrero and talking like Speedy
Gonzales when they do it yeah then I
would get upset but you know there's
plenty of Asian infused this and French
infuse that and cultures to me and all
of that [ __ ] to me it's like it's like
the MMA how I was like how good were the
martial arts when it was you were just
one discipline you know every way i i'd
i am aikido i am [ __ ] taekwondo i do
karate i [ __ ] box or whatever and
then a guy Bruce Lee comes around he's
like I'll take a little bit wasn't he
doing that you know and then he was
teaching it to [ __ ] the round-eyed
guys over here and everybody over in
Asia is like hey that's our [ __ ] don't
be showing it to their [ __ ] and now
looking now look how great the [ __ ]
fighters are you know what I mean I
would love to see Bruce Lee today if he
him back then if he got into the [ __ ]
ring you know what I mean did he ever
have to deal with a double legged take
down what would happen to him does he
have a ground in pound defense
ground-and-pound didn't exist could that
man fight on his back that's how much
it's progressed so I feel everything
should get all [ __ ] mixed up and then
[ __ ] spins out of that he just like I
think it's just when you start to act
like you're the thing that you're doing
you know what I mean like and people do
but the thing is if you start getting
into like like whatever Japanese cuisine
okay or you get into anime whatever I'm
watching this anime show but like I just
watch it and I appreciate it I don't
start walking around with the Rising Sun
[ __ ] t-shirt and I get some swords
you know criss-crossed on my walls you
know start sitting on the floor and a
pillow with a little short table you
know what I mean
I mean wait wait I don't know I don't
know where you I think it's all how you
do it I mean I find walking just an
Asian person's house and they got a
bunch of [ __ ] from Ikea I don't go like
you know your appropriate my culture
what's with that l-shaped couch but
they're also not oppressing me and I'm
not oppressing anybody but overall the
[ __ ] you know long tide [ __ ] up the
top are so that's what it really comes
down to it really I think it really
comes down to white people get held to
that standard of cultural appropriation
because you know we can the damage we
can do and we can be really ignorant
with it and then other times people are
just being kunti like I'm not going to
read this [ __ ] article but if it's
just a couple of white chicks making
Mexican food and they're crushing it you
know and they're dressed like white
chicks going like oh my god who on
Sabrina I don't think there's a problem
with that if they're killing it right
it's a [ __ ] food truck fill your pie
hole up and [ __ ] I don't know all right
girlfriend I hey man what's up I just
had a few questions sorry for the lack
of punctuation
we'll use parentheses when he said that
I flew this girl out all the way to
Japan
you know something [ __ ] you I'm not
reading this [ __ ] you know what you
rewrite this [ __ ] thing you rewrite
this [ __ ] thing okay and then I'll
read it go [ __ ] yourself sorry for the
lack of punctuation yes sorry I'm not
[ __ ] reading it there you go I draw
the line at lack of punctuation I hate
when people [ __ ] go sorry if you're
sorry you would have taken the time to
put some [ __ ] in there you didn't you're
not sorry you're [ __ ] lazy so [ __ ]
off now I'm going to be lazy right back
to you I'm not reading you goddamn [ __ ]
however if you want to fix it
put some punctuation in and I will read
it goddamn and I will read it alright
the Red Sox we're in second place and
the evil empire Yankees are in first
place those evil [ __ ] with all
their homegrown talent and here we are
the young upstarts with a 215 million
dollar team just doing anything we can
to try to keep up with them I want to
know I want to [ __ ] know because I
heard he lost a bunch of weight I know
he ended up getting [ __ ] hurt again I
want to know when Pablo's coming back I
don't know why I just feel like he said
I'm gonna have a great second half of
the season Pablo Sandoval and he's gonna
earn his goddamn money and I think the
Red Sox are they're going to catch fire
here right before the all-star break and
it's going to be Yankees Red Sox Yankees
Red Sox it's going to be great again
it's going to be [ __ ] hilarious
because now we're the [ __ ] evil
empire that could spend it 200 [ __ ]
million dollars that's my prediction
it's going to go down to them and ESPN
will blow the Yankees because they have
homegrown talent and they will [ __ ]
trash the Red Sox for spending all this
[ __ ] money like they never trash the
Yankees when they did it back in the day
because that's how it works because when
the Yankees win the World Series
ESPN goes in all is right in the
baseball universe it's just like oh so
you guys are all Yankee fans there why
does it make it right I never understood
that that they play favorites like that
but I
that's what they do so you know what
[ __ ] them [ __ ] you too have a great
couple of days I'll check in on you
on Thursday be careful around those
grills you have fatties
you